welcome back to glamour and filtered
with me Josh Smith and today we are
joined by the actress the activist and
now you're an ambassador for buffle the
women first social networking app Jamil
how the hell are you I'm alright how are
you good
[Music]
now we're here for very specific reasons
bumble done this amazing insightful
survey into loneliness and friendship
using the hashtag asking for a friend
and the campaign is all about chunking
real friendships and one of the crazy
things that come out there is that too
in free Britons feel lonely and isolated
which I found particularly like quite
scary idea it breaks my heart but also
is something that I so relate to as
someone who was so lonely until I was
like 19 I didn't really have any friends
I mean knowing kissed me so I was 21 so
I was sexually very lonely just socially
awkward socially an actor the longer you
go without friendships so how do you
find to strike them up because you've no
taboo or you feel like a loser you're
not a loser there's nothing wrong with
you everyone can be lonely at some time
I get to meet some of the most famous
people in the world they're lonely than
any is so lonely they are the loneliest
because they can't go outside yeah live
in like hotel rooms with security guards
and they can't even they don't even know
who to trust that loneliness could
happen to anyone and it's pivotal that
we've destigmatize it and stopped making
it something that anyone feels ashamed
of I didn't tell anyone for ages in it
it's what resulted in my having a bit of
a nervous breakdown when I was about 26
it's because I hadn't it just sort of
stored up in me and I just exploded at
one point because I hadn't had the
chance to let that out until then that's
why I'm so open about my mental health
because I want people to know that it's
nothing to be ashamed of and actually
you're just a warrior for making it
through every single day you should be
hugely proud of himself it's happening
to so many more people than you know and
the bravest thing you can do
speak out about it and you must and you
should and you will feel immediately
better for doing so I formally ask
people to be friends do you genuinely
like I'm not saying I'm not saying that
for this campaign like it's a it's a
sort of noted thing of mine that when I
really like someone I will formally
which which shows how socially inept I
am I still in my 30s will formally ask
someone to be my friends like to be my
friend but it's one of those things that
I used to do when I was at school
because I was super lonely when I was at
school and when you meet other people I
just was I wasn't sure about who I was
as a person come to like reconcile being
gay in like the early noughties it's
still quite crazy thing to do and that
was very isolating in itself I didn't
really have any role models look up to
you like you're like become a role model
for mental health but when we were
younger yeah there was nothing like you
couldn't do it there are studies that
link loneliness to being more
detrimental to your health and things
like tobacco
well heart problems Wow yeah because it
affects your mental health it affects
your stress levels and and your stress
levels affect the rest of your health I
wish that I'd had less pride about
asking for a friend
when I was younger I think that's
probably one of my biggest regrets is
that I didn't just tell people I feel
lonely what age would you say that was I
was brilliant
really badly throughout school I was
bullied from the age of like six until I
was seventeen that's why I didn't finish
books I got bullied so badly that I was
I actually after I got hit by a car and
it's like a year I got offered to go
back and finish school so I be able to
go to uni and I was so traumatized and
being believed that I didn't go back to
finish schooling I was like no I just I
actually can't be in that situation ever
again it felt like prison to me nice
thirteen this is sad some of the worst
school bullies at school turned up at my
house on a Saturday night and I was in
watching like the Eurovision Song
Contest with my brother and they like
turned up at my house and sort of I
thought maybe they were coming to like a
four wanted to hang out and I like no
one had ever asked me to hang out yet
and I opened the door and they were like
we do
going out and I'm watching the
Eurovision Song Contest but I don't have
to do and they were like oh cool we were
just wondering what you were up to we're
going off now bye and left me there
standing at my door oh my god thanks
Harry they came just to let me know that
they were going out and having a really
fun night and that I was alone at home
what kind of a [ __ ] with yourself did
you have in those moments when you were
super lonely in the peak times I was
horrible to myself and I didn't have a
friend to tell me not to be I was just
there sort of bullying myself when I was
younger and blaming myself for being
lonely and talking rubbish about the way
that I looked to myself and telling
myself that I wasn't good enough or just
sort of battering myself and I didn't
have anyone around to stop that from
happening and I think women in
particular are really really guilty of
doing that and and you know we it's we
talked to by society and so we really
need a sorority we really need our
friends to be able to stop us from
hurting ourselves because we have a
tendency to do that because it's what
we've learned what's your relationship
like with the sisterhood how is that
change do you think in your life it's
been so great and also within this
industry like I didn't really have any
female friends until after really time's
up and me too because there was this
real sense of competition and this
division between women and I think
because we were divided we were able to
be conquered until now and me too and
times that really brought women together
and created this true sense of community
and sorority and suddenly we had this
empathy for each other we realized we
were all going through the same thing
we'd all been holding it in by ourselves
thinking it was only happening to us and
the competition has lessened so much and
now it feels like we're genuinely happy
for each other and we're working
together and we're making a space and
not taking space one of the things as
well what you've done which is so
incredible is you've raised so much
awareness about different people's
relationships of their body image which
is such an incredible thing you've done
and you've also built a community around
it as well that journey for you how
difficult has that been and what have
you had to reconcile within yourself to
enable you to do it
you mean wither away yeah well I mean
the coolest thing for starters about our
way is the fact that it is the community
and community that I consider myself a
part of it's not my company it's my
community and I have benefited as much
from them as they have benefited from
anything that I've said and I draw so
much strength from the people in that
community and they do such brave things
like they come out on the I way account
or they they tell their parents that
they're transgender for the first time
and like take us through that journey
with them and you know you never see
negative comments on the I way accounts
you know when someone feels very
reticent about posting a picture but
they finally do it you see thousands of
lovely comments from complete strangers
just sharing that person on people make
friends via I way which i think is
really cool and I think that's why it
felt quite linear to the bumble campaign
it's been jarring because it's
constantly been a reminder for all of us
who are involved in it to keep checking
ourselves when it comes to the way that
we think about our body as we talk about
our bodies and so I think it made me
realize that I wasn't far along as far
along my recovery in my kind of eating
disorder mentality as I thought I was
and I realized I still had a way to go
to really stop that that inner voice
that inner bully that I have that tells
me bad things about myself and via a way
I have become the most confident and
powerful and self loving version of
myself that I've ever been and I
couldn't have done it without the people
in my way without that community because
I didn't respect myself and now I know I
respect myself and I demand the respect
of others and I owe that I way I think
also as well going through an eating
disorder is a very isolating thing as
well even though so many people have it
know and not enough people talk about it
either
do you ever let go of that person or you
still got her with you
I think it'll always be a tiny part of
me but that voice is like shrunken
drunken drunken drunken drunk because I
had EMDR therapy which kind of helped
get rid of the root cause of the eating
disorder but the body dysmorphia lives
with me forever and also just as a woman
because you're being constantly reminded
by a fashion or via media or Hollywood
or your friends around you in the way
that they talk about themselves or the
way that your mother talks about her
or whatever or the way your family talks
about your body you are constantly being
reminded body body body looks looks
looks worth worth worth and so it's it's
a constant struggle to kind of undo that
and unlearn that but it does become
easier and easier and I am living proof
that you can go from being the most
anorexic person you've ever heard of to
now being someone who genuinely looks at
food as fuel and doesn't beat themselves
up anymore over things like cellulite or
thighs or whatever we need to talk to
ourselves in a way that we talk to other
people yeah I mean yes there's something
that I say all the time and I weigh is
that would you take this amount of [ __ ]
from someone else that would never you
would how dare we I've said things to
myself that if someone came up to you I
said them to you I beat them up hmm I
try I try to you tried that yeah yeah
get those hills up Dave walk around yeah
if they spoke [ __ ] to you and I don't
even know you that well yeah and yet I
say these things to myself all the time
or I have previously
it's outrageous I'm so mad at myself but
I'll never do it again because once you
hear that voice you can't unhear it
you're aware of it and so that's the
coolest thing is coming out and talking
about having an inability felt like
exposing my abuser hmm and abusers can
only continue to abuse you when they're
in private and when they have anonymity
and as soon as you expose and of use
that they are unable to keep effectively
abusing you and that's what you've got
to do with your inner bully is tell your
friends tell your family you tell anyone
you can that this is going on because
it's happening to you it's not your
fault what advice would you give to
someone who's out there right now who's
gone through the same journey or right
in the middle of it that you've been on
with loneliness what would you want to
say to them I'd say it's not your fault
and you mustn't feel embarrassed about
the situation that you found yourself in
and you should go and find a bunch of
things that you love and you should go
and do those things and find people who
are
commanded we're all out here looking for
friends you can never have too many
friends you can and find your people
y'all need your people and I think that
that's so important so get out there do
it now will you be my friend off your
front a look at what great way to reload
tick new friendship right here for more
empowering videos such as this with such
epic people as Jameela Jamil make sure
you subscribe to the glamour UK channels
now
[Music]